big news out of the Elizabeth Warren  campaign did you hear this good that's  why I'm here a whole crowd no you grow  tired of this election a year ago didn't  you and we saw that way to go today  Elizabeth Warren pledged to bypass  Congress and cancel all student debt on  her first day as president yeah as a  result as a result she is polling number  one with philosophy majors huge now they  can start their philosophy store right  all that money yeah other big news the  WNBA is guaranteeing maternity leave for  its players WNBA gonna offer the Kearney  with me in response the NBA said hey if  we offered our players paternity leave  there'd be no NBA everyone's fine I want  to stress that but in Tampa a woman was  caught inside a Walmart trying to  assemble a bomb yeah yeah thority screw  suspicious when they found something in  a Walmart that was made in America  [Applause]  [Music]  mostly foreign good yeah